[Musique]
bonne journée fait 400 ans
oui retour pour terre de travail
deuxième partie de cette si massa run au
pied du taïbit tu direction hell bourg
là où on est parti vous allez voir c'est
magnifique c'est parti pour mafate
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand le projet pourquoi enrôler
voisine nos voisines
c'est bien ça en équipe
c'est cool c'est chouette de finale on y
va c'est un sport aux équipes
[Musique]
une grosse biodiversité voilà ce qui
caractérise ce lieu un espace naturel
sensible
financé par le département c'est ce
qu'on vend tout de suite cette fois on
continue
[Musique]
des salazes très connue depuis fort
longtemps où tous à un moment ou un
autre s'arrête soit pur produit 26 ans
montante ou descendante
la spécialité de nathalie ou sinon
carrément se poser mais au-delà de cet
accueil chaleureux au niveau de la
tisanerie vous avez un ems qui est vaste
qui est vraiment un jardin créole avec
tout son volet endémique et son volet
d'histoire
[Musique]
c'est un espace qui mérite une regard
particulier et un entretien particulier
parce que c'est toute une identité
culturelle identité botanique qui se
perd à la réunion et donc entre autres
les lettres des salazes fait partie de
cette ce patrimoine déception et surtout
vous avez une p le temps s'est arrêté et
on ne peut que se gérer ça au sportif
après l'effort le réconfort ce lieu s'y
prête merveilleusement bien
[Musique]
ces pics à pic après la montée et à la
descente du moment là et s'applique ou
en fait ça pique aux genoux aux jambes
mon avis ça ne m'a pas tous il l'a fait
lui préfère pas choisi sinon je dis ma
pathologie mais finalement le moment
fatal sommes les meilleurs et dans la la
balade continue des cendres du taïbit
marla changement total de végétation
john moss ferrer de température
[Musique]
cilaos si l'arrêt ce mois ci la hausse
ok pourquoi la montée du piton des
neiges
ouais le village d'al khor la fraîcheur
le village lui-même beaucoup sinon
je
voilà je pense que si tout va bien c'est
bien les gars
[Musique]
quand les goûts et à tous le vendit dans
la porte
l'une des portes les plus fréquentés de
mafate sur les 40 % du terrain n'était
pas fatigué de cirque et on est arrivé
salazie mafate on est au coeur de lille
au coeur de la forêt départementaux de
magna et qui gère ces sentiers des
sentiers qui ont souffert ces derniers
temps avec le mauvais temps
et voici loana f pour les rencontres
tout de suite tout est fait
effectivement pour que les uns pour les
randonneurs pour les courses souffrait
dans les meilleures conditions et avec
des financements et physiquement soit du
conseil départemental soit de l'europe
tout ce qui est entretien travaux de
réfection ont cette année les sentiers
ont été particulièrement impacté par les
différentes tempêtes
il y avait beaucoup d'éboulis de
glissements de terrain d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez qu'il ya encore pas mal de
100 kg et qui sont fermées soit en cours
de travaux soit en attente et donc c'est
vraiment là la sécurité qui prime avant
tout pour pouvoir assurer effectivement
des événements en toute sécurité pour
les traileurs je leur dirai bon courage
et abba continue
[Musique]
tu arrives les gars revenez faut porter
gilbert
[Musique]
servi par les agriculteurs
montcourt a dit moi ti-boutte mais bon
alors fort de se taire de travail
spécial si massa vous avez vu la chance
qu'on a d'avoir des cirques de tel
relief
là on trouvera les sentiers
[Musique]